when I have uch dases come to stay it
normally takes them two weeks every
single day of doing this before they
understand it so I don't be in a rush
don't think it's going to come
quickly what i' like to also look at now
is
um on the first two
attaching the first
attaching 10
variation where we come
here show up the arm if I move my body
away that you'll see that the sword is
in his the same place there it's
following his arm down some people do it
like this and it's okay but you've got
to get to
here to
here so the massui is important for when
you do the K taxes that you understand
the going in and coming out going in
coming
out that's just
the that one
okay and then after many years of doing
it you come to the say the the mui level
once we start getting faster errors
start to come in so I'm going to show
you an error that everybody tends to
have and that
is
here here is okay steps forward here and
here but this Fleck becomes too big it
becomes like almost like it becomes here
and now it's gone away from him so it
really needs to be more like
a change
over this goes like this and it's going
away from him where it should be like
a a
rolling a rolling
over again from the
head to the wrist it should be
like
rolling
over if you watch my center and and the
Ken together it's as if my hands are
being
rolled by my by my sent at this point
so so we're here here as I lift off my
sensor
look my
sens so then we have the whole mubi
so that was a roll rather than a a
lift okay come on